Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Yeah.
Ah,
just checking in on you.
Just checking in on you,
seeing how you're doing.
You having a good week.
Are you enjoying yourself?
I hope you're having a good fucking week.
Uh,
I hope it's going better than my week.
uh,
I don't know if I'll fucking,
I'll get right into it.
Uh,
unfortunately a,
a great comedian,
grade friend,
just one of the best people I haven't met,
uh,
passed away yesterday.
Charlie Murphy and um,
can't fucking believe it,
man.
Really cannot believe it.
I had,
um,
I hadn't talked to him in about a year and I had no idea that,
that he was sick to that level.
So,
uh,
I think it's still hitting me,
man.
It's unbelievable.
I'm so sick of fucking hilarious.
Great people dying.
I was actually talking with a friend of mine the other day.
I was just like,
dude,
to hacks ever die.
Like what?
When was the last time somebody who truly sucked at standup comedy died?
It's fucking unbelievable.
What a hacks.
Eat this.
If I was
fired the fucking money,
I swear to God I'd get,
I get to get,
you know,
maybe,
it's funny,
I actually realize halfway through that said I'm still alive.
So when I kind of shitting on myself,
somebody got to put together the hack diet,
whatever that is.
Those motherfuckers lived to be like 85,
90.
Um,
anyways,
another just giant.
I mean you're talking about somebody who,
when I met him in 2004 had already lived like four lifetimes.
He had four unbelievable books from his childhood to his teenage years in,
in early twenties living in Brooklyn and all this shit that he did to going into
the navy,
to his brother blowing up and then him getting out of the navy and work in
security on the tour and then morphing in to like a screen writer and actor.
And then he gets on the Chappelle show,
just was sitting around us was that it was told to me just telling these stories
of,
you know,
back in the day,
hanging out with everyone from prince to Rick James,
you've seen all those things,
stories about Whitney Houston.
He just sugar ray Leonard,
Oj Simpson.
He just like that sketch,
which to this day I'm telling you is I think it's the greatest sketch of all
time,
the Charlie Murphy True Hollywood story about Rick James.
And uh,
I remember him telling me afterwards,
I was just like,
dude,
how true is that shit?
And he goes,
well yeah,
obviously we exaggerate.
Like,
you know,
he didn't,
when he hit me in the head I didn't have a unity,
you know,
thing and on my head.
But he's like,
yeah he did.
They were like in the back of the limo or something.
And,
you know,
Rick just kind of went to,
he was trying to be like friendly,
but it's like God,
they kind of hit Charlotte like hard enough in their head that I guess Eddie and
his friends were waiting for Charlie react cause they knew her.
Charlie was Charlie Kinda got mind fuck for half a second thinking like,
you know,
I'd stomped the shit out of anybody who did this to me,
but it's Rick James.
And it kind of took them like an hour before he was like,
fuck this.
And uh,
you know,
obviously didn't kick them up on a dresser,
but he did fucking rough them up a little bit in the back room.
And then when the security came in,
he did bring them over to the window and said that he was going to throw him
out.
They came anywhere near him.
So um,
yeah man,
it's just really a really a sad day and that guy was just,
and he was such a great guy.
I told you guys this story before,
he saved my fucking ass one time.
Um,
I was trying to get in shape,
right.
As always as I always am.
I was living in New York City and uh,
I started going down to Gleason's gym out in Brooklyn,
you know,
cause I didn't want to get all fucking,
I was joking.
Hillary Swank is,
I believe what I was calling myself and they were giving me shit because I just
went down there and an actor performer kind of way to get in boxing shape
without ever fucking,
you know,
getting my head kicked in.
So when I told Charlie that I was going down to Gleason's gym,
he goes,
I just want to go going,
oh yeah,
okay,
I'm going to tell you what's going to happen
because you'll be able to have about six weeks and out of nowhere he goes,
some dude's going to come up to you and start telling you,
it'd be like a,
how long have you been boxing for?
Really are man,
you nice man,
you're not shooting.
We had a sparse some time.
He goes,
he's gonna fucking,
he's going to amp you all up to get you into the ring so he can try out a bunch
of shit that he does that he's not dumb enough to try out on a professional
boxer and he's going to beat the fuck out of you.
And I was just like,
and he just started laughing at me.
I'm like,
Hey,
I get the fuck Outta here.
Get the fuck I do.
I'm telling you,
I was like raw,
whatever time.
He said,
three weeks or six weeks,
it was like right on the nose.
I'm sitting there,
you know,
and the heavy bag,
like the comedian slash sometimes act or I am hitting the bag like [inaudible]
right in this fucking black dude.
Shredded comes over.
He's like,
Yo man.
He goes,
well,
how long have you been,
how long you've been box?
It was like,
it was almost like Charlie's head was on the guys head.
He said the exact same thing.
Oh Man,
United Smith,
you want to get in the fucking ring and all this shit.
And I just started laughing.
I just started laughing.
I was like,
I go,
man,
fuck,
I'll fuck like I'm a fucking comedian.
Um,
horrific.
I'm not getting in there so you can try out all your new shit on me.
And the guy just started laughing,
threw his head back,
laughed,
then walked away.
And it was so weird.
I was like,
that guy was going to beat the fuck out of me.
So then I told them to Charlie thinking that he would be amazed
that,
you know,
like,
like dude,
I called it,
what the fuck did I say?
And he was just like,
yeah,
he's like,
I told you he did that like a million times.
Like he just had this,
um,
I dunno,
he had like this fucking sixth sense.
And I'd tell you some of those other stories,
the Oj one in the Whitney one,
but I just feel like those are hit.
That was what his stories to tell.
And if you wanted to share him,
he would've,
but,
um,
so I can only tell you the ones I remember when we won that Chappelle show tour,
it was me,
you know,
dawn,
Al Ashy,
Larry and him.
And Charlie was the guy who actually showed me that you could write a new hour
of material in two months because I saw him do it
cause he blew up,
you know,
on on the second season with that,
that Rick James Story
and um,
all of this,
Don l came up with the idea for the tour.
He was like,
you know,
Yo son,
we should go out on tour,
blah blah.
So,
you know,
we'll have bill open up,
we'll bring you out Charlie,
you can host it.
And then Don l would close.
And um,
I think Charlie maybe did,
this is the fucking balls this guy had,
I think he did maybe six shows before we did our first show.
And I believe it was Dayton,
Ohio.
And we didn't even have an agent and Donald book the thing.
And uh,
so we went out there.
I was like the only white guy in the room in the theater.
And we went out there and Charlie hosts anyone out and just went,
Charlie Murphy,
you know,
uh,
I'm Rick James Bitch or something like that place went fucking nuts.
He told like two more jokes brought me out.
And everybody's looking at me like,
who the fuck is this guy?
Is this one of the writers?
This is one of the creators.
Is this the agent on the tort?
Nobody had any idea who the fuck I was.
So I did my bullshit.
Charlie came out and told another couple of jokes and then don l close to show
everybody had a great time.
And um,
afterwards we went into the back room.
Okay,
now we're in the green room and there's like 20 people in there and we don't
know anybody.
Once again,
I'm the only white dude in there.
Me,
Don,
Ellen Charlia sitting at this table and all of a sudden these two guys come up.
What was it at one guy I can't remember,
and just had like a fucking bag of cash from that night's Gig Edge.
He had it all bandaged up and just threw it on the table and it all spilled out.
And it was just sitting there
and I was sitting there like,
what the fuck?
And Darnell and Charlie did move.
So I didn't move and I was just sitting there as the white dude,
like going,
I guess this is how black people pay each other.
They have 20 complete strangers in the fucking room,
drinking and partying and then just a bunch of cash.
I fell like we robbed a bank or something.
So we sat there,
I swear to God for at least one more mob deep song or whatever the fuck was
playing at that time.
The Thong Song,
I can't remember what era it was.
And uh,
finally I forget it was either Donnelle or Charlie just soda casually sat up and
just took the money,
put it in the bag and then put it down by their side,
which made me relax a little bit more.
And I was just like,
I was sitting there going like,
I don't think I'm ready for this fucking tour.
This is not the way you get paid at the funny bone.
So we stayed there maybe for like another half hour and then we finally go up to
get up to leave and we're just walking out and you just feel an eyeballs honest.
Cause we got this big bet,
it's just cash.
And we go out,
we get into the fucking,
they had rented this fucking Limo Force.
We got in the car and the second the car door is closed and we start driving
away,
Darnell just goes,
Yo,
what the fuck?
And Charlie was just freaking out and I just start and I was just like,
just the epiphany that they were actually freaking out to what,
I had no idea.
You'd never know looking at their face.
I'm sure everybody in the room knew that I was fucking uncomfortable.
And um,
suffice to say,
after that we got ourselves an agent and uh,
we got,
we got paid by check after that.
It was just us in the room.
Um,
and that was that infamous tour where they would always make fun of,
that's where that Joe came from.
You know,
this mother fucker got five shirts.
Um,
that's where that one came from because they always made fun of my clothes.
And there was that time when I was hung over and I just didn't want to get in
the car and deal with this shit.
And they had taught me about the Itis,
which was basically when you eat like a food that's rich in flavor but low in
fucking nutrition you body,
you end up taking a quick cat nap cause your body literally has to shut
everything else down to figure out how to digest what you just put in your
stomach.
So I was standing outside this hotel hung over as hell and I just thought,
oh my God,
we were doing that.
Used to be the,
it was the Chicago xannies and then you do Mount Vernon and then uh,
Saint Charles,
it was his three Gig run through the Northern Illinois.
I forget what we just unsane he's and I was too drunk.
I had a fucking headache and I'm walking out,
try and get fresh air going.
I've got to deal with these two fucking assholes all the way up to this club.
It's a two hour drive.
The nonstop going to be fucking hammering me.
I looked down the street and there was a Popeye's and I just remember them
telling me about the itis and I said,
fuck this.
And I went down there,
I got a bucket of chicken biscuits with mashed potatoes,
gravy,
all of that shit.
And I brought it into the end of the fucking limo and I was like,
hey guys,
I've got some food that,
ah,
Greg,
you know,
and they dug it and they started eating and I didn't have one piece of it and
swear to God within 20 minutes they were both asleep.
And I had,
they slept the entire fucking ride.
I basically poisoned a
temporary poison him and it worked like a Goddamn charm.
And,
um,
I dunno,
I just,
I,
I had to say something about Charlie's still too sad to really get into the
feelings of aliveness,
but um,
he truly was one,
not only
one of the most amazing just lives of anybody ever lived.
He just was truly one of the best guys that,
um,
that I haven't met in this business.
So.
All right,
that's it.
No getting emotional on the podcast.
Okay,
so let's get back to the rest of this stuff here.
Um,
the fucking Bro,
it's,
ah,
finally the first time all year we beat the Ottawa senators.
All right.
Beat him when it counts.
Like,
I didn't even realize they beat us all four times this year.
Well,
congratulations.
Ottawa capital of Canada,
you know,
but unfortunately your full game winning streak came to an end,
right when it counted.
Okay.
You are the weirdest part of that game was,
was listening to a loud,
Otto was centered offense.
You know,
I actually know something.
I used to think that tiff fans would just lean.
But the real reason is Ottawa.
It's just like Washington DC,
you know,
it's the capital.
So there's a bunch of people from all over the fucking country.
So there's a bunch of conduct fans,
flames,
oiler fans,
all that bullshit.
They're sitting there,
they don't give a fuck about the senators,
you know?
So it's not the people,
the Ottawa,
they're great people.
They got a little fucking river that they freeze over.
You Skate to work does not.
They made,
it's like a fucking fantasy line up there.
It's one of my favorite cities.
I actually like it for some reason they say auto or the city that fun for God.
Well,
you know what,
I always have a great time when I go there.
Um,
and um,
what a fucking great game though.
Autoplay grade.
I by no means think that victory means that we're going to win the series.
I think it's gonna I think it was two to one.
I feel like the whole s series is going to kind of go like that and it's going
to get even,
uh,
not even shippy.
I think it might get a little ugly.
Um,
Brad Marshawn back from his suspension doing what he does.
Score and big goals and big games.
Um,
hey nia.
Camair
okay,
I didn't know that.
Brad Mars.
Sean,
where are you?
Okay.
I had never heard this nickname.
Brad Marshawn.
They call them nose face killer.
Cause,
and I thought I was being so original when I called that guy on a fuck.
That's because he sounds like ghost face killer.
I called him pot roast pot rose face killer.
Is that what I was
here I am on my hat.
Look at that parallel thinking parallel thought.
There you go.
Is that what it's called?
What?
Do you know more than I do?
Is that what's said behind my back?
No,
I'm doing all right.
The Bruins one.
I haven't been on the podcast in a while.
Now you have it once you grab the mic,
grab a microphone to come on in here.
I'll hit pause.
All right.
Went Back.
I got the microphone and everything like that.
The lovely Nia.
Hello.
How they hell?
Hell yeah.
The hell you Ben.
I know.
Long time.
No Fuck Hell podcasts.
No,
I don't think you've really been on that much since.
Uh,
we had the little princess here.
That's right.
Who's sitting here.
You know what's funny is because you know her hair still short and everything
and all of our friends had boys and they just gave us all their clothes.
Everyone keeps thinking it's a boy
and she just came in.
Now she's got a little shirt on.
That is like a classic,
that looks like a 1955 Chevy pickup truck on it.
So yeah.
So a everyone,
yeah,
everyone thinks that she is a boy,
but that's okay.
She will not be defined by her gender rights.
Yes,
she will put on a dress for God sakes.
I liked the little play close though.
I think they're so cute.
Well,
yeah,
I mean I don't care either way.
You know you look good to me.
That kiddo.
Yeah.
She doesn't have to be like all frilly and princess looking.
I'm not really into that anyway.
What do you say it?
What do you mean?
Well,
at some point you mean you got to put her with some girls clothes,
right?
Yeah.
I have plenty of girls clothes for her.
Okay.
You scare me there.
Why?
What do you,
why?
Why are you scared?
Well,
I mean at some point you didn't keep,
can't say ever walking around with like,
you know,
Pete Carroll,
dockers and stuff,
you know,
but well now we're not going to do that.
But like I think how she's daddy's little girl,
but I think little girls look cute and like little boy clothes,
like the little tomboy.
Look,
I think that's cute.
You know what is,
yeah.
As long as she has clothes on into diapers clean at this point,
I'm happy.
Right.
I really don't care what it is
exactly it.
But so anyways,
she wore a cute little dress on Easter,
remember?
Oh yes,
she did.
I remember how much of been she went to East to west.
So he used to bought it.
Yeah.
It's not like we go to church or anything like that.
Where he then,
oh,
by the way,
Leah,
did I tell you about that great band I saw the other night?
Oh,
you mean the one with Davey?
Let's,
yeah,
the guy have been taking drum lessons from,
you know,
one of the best farmers in the world right now.
Shout out to Davy.
That's right.
He plays drums in this band called the night game and they have a new single
out,
if you want to check it out.
It's on iTunes.
It's called the,
um,
the outfield.
And,
uh,
I saw them play like a quick half hour set the other night,
right.
Uh,
over capitol records were across the street from that.
Remember when I walked over and then had my,
my issue,
have you done that?
I've been doing cardio like a madman.
Maybe some,
some arenas can to ease of advice about this brutal cardio like a madman,
but like Jordan shorts on and I don't know what happened by balls.
My Ball,
one of them was just,
I just did too much walking in one day and I had a little chafing issue on one
side of the old bag there.
And uh,
it did not affect my enjoyment of the band cause I walked like,
it's like a two mile walk over there or something.
Right.
What are you doing?
You're looking at me or you're going to hurt two miles over.
And then two miles back in that after I'd already done an hour of cardio.
So the next day I was walking like I wrote a horse for like six weeks straight.
But anyways,
I went over and saw this show and they have a singer,
a Martin Johnson.
Amazing singer.
And then two killer guitarist.
I hope they say these names right.
A Kirin j
you go colonian Max Bernstein.
And then they had a guy sitting in on base,
uh,
Andrew Peruzzi and uh,
two days sounded fucking,
I mean it's really like poppy type stuff,
but the level of musicianship,
how great they all sounded live.
Um,
definitely check it out.
Once again,
it's called the name of the band is the night game and the single is the
outfield and that is outright now.
So can we talk about your chief balls?
Oh,
it's done.
It was just what I was one and done was one day of uncomfortableness.
Oh,
you're okay now.
Oh yeah.
Oh good.
Okay.
I was suggesting that bill gate gold bombs medicated powder because I just felt
like that was just something that you just dust on your balls a little bit.
He kept saying,
you know,
like when those great chefs put the powdered sugar on chronic infections,
do that little,
but no,
I think that's your balls a little bit to keep it.
That's not for chafing.
No,
that's,
but I thought that's what people have itchy balls,
itchy balls and they're sweaty.
And so therefore,
so then I'm like this,
it's a culture.
Like you're going to make bread but it's your ball red ball.
That's disgusting.
No,
this is just a,
yeah,
a chafing.
You know what I mean?
Gary Chafee.
Alright.
She's chiming in here.
The third Mike.
Um,
anyways,
it's funny.
Anyways.
Yeah.
So that is,
uh,
that is all,
this is going to be difficult.
And I mean,
you know,
we got the third one.
I don't know.
Well this is why the heads to me.
Why,
you know,
Hans,
what are likely,
you haven't been on the podcast in a while because they,
you know,
I have,
so I have to watch her.
She is,
look how happy she is.
She's such a happy baby.
I'm actually,
it's like that.
She's really chill.
And so people keep saying she's a really relaxed,
happy baby,
which is unbelievable considering she lives with me and I've been doing,
I've been going really hard with the whole trying to be chill.
Right.
Have a good job.
I'll go and really hard with the Chili.
Yeah.
He always had to take it to the extreme.
I know you said to me the other day,
did you have you been meditating lately?
That's when I know getting a little up to the little press a piece there.
Press a piece.
Yeah.
So I got,
uh,
I got a fucking,
I got to handle that type of stuff.
So,
um,
hey,
the Celtics got the number one seat,
then number one,
lead number one seat in the east.
So we get some seed.
S e d like what I've put in,
you have to have their babies,
except this is like,
yes,
that's a good point.
The balls are going to definitely be tough.
We're not trying to look past them and uh,
it was just was a great night as far as uh,
you know,
considering the tragedy of yesterday,
the broads wherein the Habs lose weight.
But tell me what a seed is again.
Just like,
did you know they'll have whatever at this 10 teams you just ranked the number
one seed means you have the best record.
Why do they use the word seed?
You know what?
I don't know.
Hope I'm saying that right.
It's not,
yeah,
the number one seat.
Yeah.
The uh,
I don't know why they call it that is what is the position,
what do you want to call?
So then when you get to the,
you were rewarded for having your best for having the best record.
We're number one gets to play the lowest person that just made the playoffs.
So you get to kind of go an easier way to go through class and it's also,
it kind of makes it so when you get to the later rounds that the best teams are
playing in,
the stakes are even higher.
This is to go to the NBA final.
Gotcha.
This is to go to the,
uh,
you know,
this is the when the whole damn thing,
except in hockey,
hockey of course they do everything weird where,
you know,
for whatever reason,
um,
like Pittsburgh has to play the blue jackets.
And I would've thought that I was like the capital's,
I would've thought they would've got Toronto.
I Dunno,
I don't get how they do it over there,
but I've,
that's definitely hockey.
But we won.
We won the shit in a,
sorry,
I'm all distracted today.
Um,
I have to read some advertising.
Is there anything you want to give me?
Shit about my balls are better than it was only one of them.
Good.
Hello?
I mean,
I'm glad you used what I gave you for them.
And I'm also like a,
a,
I'm like a plane.
You know what I mean?
Like one of those big jet planes,
the,
they can lose one engine still flying,
so I'm fine.
I'm fine.
Ghastly.
I know.
Why was it only the one ball?
I don't know.
Why is one ball bigger than the other?
Is that why it's like rubbing a little bit more now?
Is it like how,
you know,
you know what,
it probably your boobs are different sizes now.
It probably has more to be with my awful posture,
my back being fucked up and one shoulder in front of the other one.
I'm just a mess.
I'm all for all this years of hanging onto the anger and not stretching.
Um,
just to twist it up and mess.
But I'll tell you I happened stretching.
I would go to a chiropractor and of of uh,
I'm a sous regularly for almost suck a year.
And had I not done that,
God knows what would have,
I probably would have lost a nut.
What I still need to know cause I asked you and you weren't sure what a jock
strap is used for.
Jock strap is same as a cup and now it's,
you control it.
It,
uh,
it holds all your,
your junk.
It just has no consideration whatsoever for your ass.
I've never understood,
I've never run a storm.
It's sort of the male thong.
And if you don't want like guy underwear lines,
I don't know why your ass is all the way out.
I don't know what it is.
I don't know what the four for source sports though.
It's called a jockstrap.
It's for a jocks.
Well let's look it up.
Let's have this on my search engine.
What's the deal?
What's the deal with watts with y jock straps.
Yeah.
All
right.
A jock strap is also known as a Jock,
jock straps,
straps,
supporter or athletic supporter,
and is an undergarment for supporting the male genitalia during cycling sports
or other vigorous physical activity.
Oh,
it's a sports bra for your penis.
Yeah.
If he had junk.
So now lop all over the place.
Yeah,
but evidently you don't mind if your ass is hanging out and now commonly worn as
everyday underwear.
Fashion job laughs.
Appear in variety of colors.
Do they?
Yes,
they do.
Well now you to go image Nia,
you go,
you want to look at some designer jock straps.
I actually really do.
Let's,
Oh hey.
You'd go,
wow.
There's one for you.
It's a great asset.
And that guy,
my God,
that was like reverse Victoria's secrets.
That was fucking horrible.
All right,
and is your answer.
You had a nice ass.
You have to have a nice ass if you're going to model those things,
right?
Yeah.
It's like if nobody wants to look at,
you know,
the same way a woman with a flat s and a Thong is one of the worst things you
could ever see.
Yeah.
You need a new literally,
see you don't like it doesn't disappear.
You can see the hole,
you can see the whole thing.
MMM,
that's right.
All the way to the front.
Okay,
well I got to do some sort of a,
I got to do a little reading out loud and I don't want my daughter to know how
dumb I am.
So if you guys,
I'm not kicking you out but I'm just saying if you want to block your ears,
ear muffs here.
Um,
you read to her all the time.
He read great.
I actually do a good job with those books.
But you know,
you also add lib throughout the entire book.
Kind of like the way you do advertising.
You don't,
it was like this weird thing where the guys,
the ducks,
like an absence seat.
Father,
he has like six kids with these like guy taken off going to Boston common,
I'll meet you over there.
It's like I trust you.
You're a good mother.
And she's just like,
yeah,
well you know,
I am.
She did everything but say,
yeah,
this is where I belonged.
When granted the book was written in like the 30s or the forties and then the
Little Mermaid Little Mermaid were,
yeah,
that whole thing was weird.
It's like she looks up love at first sight with the prince.
Yeah,
he's got his own effin boat.
Can't curse when she's here.
I probably already did the dead,
Huh?
That's okay.
That's all right.
Nice little cutie pie girl curse and I think it's hilarious.
That warms my heart.
No right upside everybody.
Okay,
here's some advertising.
Sorry.
Okay.
Hey guys.
I discovered something really big.
I going to tell you,
I have no idea what this is,
so I haven't discovered anything.
I'm just reading the shit.
The best new wave for you to buy travel.
It's called upside.com here's why I love it even though I've never seen it and
why everyone I tell loves it.
Every time you buy a trip at upside,
you save a ton of money and they give you an Amazon gift card worth 100 200 even
$300 every time.
That makes no sense.
How would they make any money?
Like a plane ticket costs 300 bucks.
You get a hundred bucks back.
What are you flying people's express you and you'll value jet there.
The way,
uh,
the way they do it is really clever.
Upside bundles,
your flights and hotels together for one low price bundle prices saves money.
Oh,
the southern till.
It especially like giving you the secret formula,
especially on business travel.
So upside gives you free Amazon gift cards.
I'm telling you,
if you're a frequent basis,
if you're a frequent business travel,
your company saves a ton of money and you can get uh,
get thousands a year,
thousands a year just for buying your air and hotel together at upside plus,
Oh God,
this is so long.
You still get all of your miles,
Jesus Christ.
These guys are given the whole thing away.
You'd be crazy not to checkout upside.com if you're shopping the business pretty
for business or personal travel.
It takes just three months to see how much you saved by buying your flights and
hotel together at one low price.
I can't believe it's taken this long for someone to do it.
You have it dentally,
possibly disk,
possibly discuss speaking with Jay Walker here.
I've,
I don't know who that is and check out what I've arranged for you.
Use My name burpee.
You rr.
And you're guaranteed to get at least $200 Amazon gift card for your first trip.
My name burpee you are,
gets you at least $200 in case you didn't hear that two seconds ago on Amazon
Gift Card for free.
How can you not do it?
It's a no brainer.
Save big on traveling.
Get big gifts.
Sorry.
They capitalize those.
A cart,
a big gift card every trip.
Um,
upside.com,
upside.com minimum purchase required.
See the site for complete details.
I got to tell you,
that almost sounds too good to be true.
Uh,
why would they want,
why would they give you all of that and get you on the plane?
Who's behind that?
Nia.
Isis.
I don't think.
All right,
let me undies.
Oh yeah,
get out of here for the song lives,
but [inaudible] me [inaudible] me undies.
Where in a night?
Jock strap,
Doo Doo Doo Doo beyond ease me undies.
Your balls are fine,
but you're asking.
It's the clap because hanging out for the whole world is,
see they never see you junk unless you have to pee by Sammy undies.
The balls are nice velvet rope.
It's like him.
You know what it is?
It's like when you're wearing a jock strap,
it's like your junk is in VIP and your ass is on the dance floor too,
so can end like I love it.
Hey Man,
can I be a,
can I get in there and pop some bottles?
All right.
Mandy's elevates your underwear game to the next level with me undies.
You've perfected your wardrobe,
but what about this stuff?
Not everybody gets to see if you've been settling for store bought underwear,
five packs that a child put in there at three in the morning and Honduras.
I have something that will change your life for the better me undies.
What's the first thing you put on in the last thing you take off?
It's your underwear.
Unless you Matthew mcconaughey,
uh,
make your most important piece of clothing the best it can be with me undies.
What is Mandy's?
What God's name is it.
Ah,
just seriously soft.
Feel good undies delivered right to your door.
[inaudible] these are designed in La,
Louisiana,
Los Angeles.
Nobody knows and made from sustainably source micro modal,
modal fabric,
three times softer than cotton,
allegedly Biondi softer than soft luxury undies come in an ever changing
selection of classic colors,
bold shapes and adventurous patterns.
So you can tailor your undies to your own personal style.
And Mondays,
why don't you make ya?
Let's see your,
your take on the jock strap with your,
your modal,
your micro modal.
Just take loan down.
Oh Dow tickling the taint.
And guess what?
You can save time and money each month.
What?
The monthly subscription immune.
If you're not ready for a subscription,
that's okay.
You can still save.
Relax.
That's because me undies is offering you 20% off your first pair.
Just use our special URL,
[inaudible] dot com slash burr and get 20% off your first pair.
So go ahead revamp your underwear drawer.
You deserve it.
Once again,
that's [inaudible] dot com slash [inaudible] dot com slash [inaudible] all
right,
Jesus Christ.
Two more to go.
Hey Nia,
have you ever heard of legal zoom?
I have both.
Good.
You're going Monday morning podcast.
Oh,
that was wonderful.
Number one,
reliability.
More than a million people have already trusted legal soup to help start their
business and corporations,
Llcs,
nonprofit,
Cbas and more.
Use Legal Zoom to get started the right way now,
but to experience you can count on legal zoom for all the details.
They've been helping all types of business owners for over 15 years.
They're not afraid.
You walk in,
I know the jackass with two arms.
Put them in a shirt.
Go ahead.
What should deal?
They'll handle it.
Number three,
helpful support like a jock strap.
They have the right people standing by ready for your question,
all based in the u s America making it great again.
Number four already.
Are there legal advice?
Legal.
Zoom isn't a law firm,
but they have a network of independent attorneys.
Oh,
like better call Saul Old Joe to Rosa crushing it on the first episode.
They can review supplier contracts,
help with your employment laws,
and advise you on many of the hurdles that pop up when you're running a
business.
And finally,
number five,
no surprises.
Legal Zoom provides complete transparency with upfront pricing,
customer reviews,
and a satisfaction guarantee.
Checkout legal zoom today to see how they can make life better for you and your
business.
And don't forget to enter Burt checkout to save even more legalzoom.com and
lastly,
but not leastly.
Hey Sweetie,
you might want some of these,
Huh?
You know she's got this new,
she acts.
She's already figured out how to make the pout face to try to manipulate me to
pick her up.
And you know what,
God dammit,
it works every time.
Alright.
DSTL jeans,
Delta Sierra,
Tango,
Lima genes.
Great genes don't have to,
they're not to be complicated with the thumper if you're not crazy.
It's a crazy stitching.
The diamonds and embedded studs,
you're not alone.
I know that taking a shot at true religion,
religion,
jeans,
are they still in business and now they are.
They must be in Charlotte.
Yeah.
Is still in business at like the local kitty parks with those are dad jeans now,
right?
They're all baggy and shit and all that.
Like anywhere.
It doesn't anymore.
Nobody wears it.
It's over.
There was to cut.
There's only two people I knew that bought those in my,
my,
my circle rich vos rich vos and Bobby Kelly,
both of them.
They're under those disco clothes.
Designer energy.
Absolutely.
I think one of them had their name in,
in,
in Diann mills on the back of his ass.
I swear to God he did.
I think rich vos in the back of his true religion jeans had first white guy on
def jam and,
and genuine Diann mills.
Was he the first white guy on def jam you just made?
That's what was on his head shot when I first met him.
Uh,
it's hilarious.
It was a picture of him doing def jam.
Oh,
there you go.
That's right.
To show you making history,
breaking barriers,
right.
Richard Vase.
This is one small step for a white man.
One giant leap for all white men,
comedians,
Ms. Rich Abbas.
I don't,
I hope you hear this rich.
Go Fuck Yourself.
He's not going to hear it.
He's out on a golf course.
Rich Vos has been like officially retired.
The way he's been living since I met him.
He lives the good life.
He calls more than Trump by the way.
I love that Trump has just gotten his ass off.
It's the greatest thing ever.
You can you just show you how like,
like that job is not that big a deal.
Clearly not to him.
Oh,
oh.
Are you talking about,
you don't think Obama was playing highlight.
He played some nerd sport
basketball.
No,
he didn't.
He shot one free throw every election.
Every he's like,
oh my God.
Stop.
Like he crossed somebody's over.
All right.
Does still pronounced distilled offers luxury grade denim at an affordable
price.
Jeans that would normally cost you hundreds.
Dstl d has started at just 75 bucks that utilize the same fabrics,
factories and wash houses as the best known brands and designers while skipping
the markups.
And the middlemen.
The result,
I was going to say,
hey,
you little kids come together.
The result,
pure,
unadulterated denim without the retail run around.
Just go to [inaudible] dot com spelled d e s t l d.com and see where minimalists
designed meets maximum comfort.
It's not like you're trying to sell me a condo.
They guarantee the fifth time share,
they'll share.
They'll ship them to you for free.
That's what,
that's what a jock strap is.
It's like a timeshare for your ass up your ass.
Debbie gets in the house,
they guarantee the fit.
They'll ship them to you for free and give you free returns until you find the
perfect pair.
Dstl d distilled has been featured in Forbes times and tech crunch as well as on
denim clad celebrities in Gq and vogue or Jay Leno who's a denim Khaled
celebrity that you know John Travolta during urban cowboy and denim clad
celebrities.
Yeah,
like they wear denim all the time.
They're cladded in it.
Cladded glad to still does the only place in the u s you can get this quality of
denim for this price point.
You can find their amazing selections of outerwear,
leather jackets,
tee shirts,
and more using the same principles of high grade materials at low end costs.
All of a sudden they got the hiccups.
Even celebrities are wearing distilled.
Um,
I've got a pair name,
the gene style,
and they've,
the fit is perfect.
You know what?
I can't fit in them yet.
Really?
I thought you did.
Maybe I did when they first gave him.
Then I went up to a buck 90 when we went over to Europe and I was smoking cigars
and he stands look nice though.
I love those jeans on you.
Oh,
you know,
they look even better.
Folded up on my shelf.
I,
uh,
I'm down to one 76.
There you go.
Yeah,
that was one 80 for a couple of weeks back.
Um,
I'm uh,
down eight pounds.
Very proud of myself.
Even celebrity or distilled is your answer to elevated style without elevated
prices.
Just go to distill.com/bar right now and get 10% off your first pair.
That's distilled.com.
[inaudible] dot com slash bar for 10% off right now.
Nia do it.
Let me hear you.
D S Delta,
Sierra,
tango,
Lima,
Delta and ice Dotcom.
Slash.
Firm.
I right.
Look at that 38 minutes went by just like that.
So that is the podcast are one last shout out.
I got to tell ya,
we low wallet Jr.
Remember that guy?
Um,
I can't say fub was his song.
I know we've already dropped the F bomb,
but I'm trying.
I'm trying people.
All right.
And he has a new album coming out.
Wheeler Walker jr his new album,
all wheeler,
all WHEELA is coming out June 2nd and it can be purchased now on Amazon.
Prepurchase sorry,
on Amazon and on iTunes.
That's my birthday.
Is June.
Really?
What?
When is this album coming out?
June 2nd that's my birthday.
I always forget.
I always even think it's the second or the third to you really.
Is that true?
You're not that important to me.
Oh my God.
But you know what I used to think of your birthday was on the eighth but we're
not good with dates.
No,
we're not.
We don't want to anniversary.
When's our ones are,
don't tell these people.
But to,
can you name our wedding anniversary?
I always get confused.
So do I.
It's a,
it's fine if we tell them no.
Okay.
Something has to be for,
I feel like no,
some of that has to be for us.
Well we never show pictures from it.
Um,
so you don't know.
I do.
It's either does it start with a one or a two?
It's as are the two,
but I don't know what the second,
this is great because now I can never get in trouble.
You'll be like,
you're on the road on our anniversary.
It's like what did you look it up?
You don't even know what it is.
I am fairly certain that I know it.
Yeah,
that's it.
Do you know what?
I had to think about it the other day.
We know the month,
but yeah,
we got that going right.
How does this relationship work?
I don't know,
but it's been going for 13 years,
so obviously we're doing something right and we have this one.
You skated away from that really quickly.
Let's not try to analyze this.
Let's not pull any sticks out of the popsicle house here.
Um,
so what's going on today?
Am I watching her at all?
Yes.
When,
um,
when a well,
you're especially watching her later today while I get my eyelashes.
All right,
cool.
You want to watch the playoff hockey?
The black cops are playing tonight?
No.
And also I take a shower and try to feel human.
Okay,
cool.
All right,
well that's it.
All right.
That's the podcast for this Thursday.
Have a great weekend.
And um,
that's it.
Once again,
check out all the stuff I told you to check out that I now don't have in front
of me.
Davey leaches band.
What the hell did I say it?
Nightlife.
Why am I the worst night game?
Night game.
Wheeler Walker jr his new album and um
Huh.
Okay.
That's,
that's it.
They get it.
We have a baby stuff and yeah,
that's it.
That would be the podcast.
I will check it out.
Not Checking your,
I'll talk to you on Monday.
Have a greet.
Great weekend.
You see notes?
I can't say it.
She's here.
Could you get out of the room please so you can for your tag so I can deliver my
tagline.
All right.
Did they go the two beautiful ladies have a great weekend.
Get cuts.
[inaudible]
it's bill burr Monday morning podcast for a Wednesday,
April 15th.
That's when I'm recording this anyways.
And a buddy of mine tomorrow is going to help me upload this fucking thing onto
my computer and then onto the g cast thing and hopefully they did it and if they
did,
you're actually listening to it,
you know?
And uh,
this is my new recording device.
How does it sound?
Huh?
You like this?
You'll like it to sound good.
It's stereo.
Motherfuckers.
Finally,
after years of you people bitching at me about the sound of my cell phone and
you know,
the tapping of my computer and all that type of shit,
I am 90% there to have an,
a really great sounding podcast.
I'm going all out.
You know,
I'm getting a microphone.
This thing has the ability that you can actually stick a cord in there,
have a microphone,
and be able to walk around like Mike Douglas when I do these.
And,
uh,
I think it's just going to help the quality all the way around.
I hope it sounds good.
I hope that,
uh,
you know,
I listened back to a couple of these.
You can literally hear the echo in my room,
um,
because that's the way I live my life.
30 sparsely,
very sparsely furnished apartment,
you know,
I,
uh,
yeah,
that's how I live my life.
I throw shit out all the fucking time.
You know,
you ever see like these people,
uh,
by the time they're 60 years old,
you know,
they're fucking sleeping on their roof because every time they went to a
baseball game and it was headband day,
they,
they just took it.
You know,
you don't have to take that shit.
I always just say,
I don't want it.
And they look at me like,
what do you mean you don't want?
And I'm like,
I don't like clutter.
You know,
I don't need a fucking Baltimore Ravens Tal to wave in the fucking air.
I don't,
you know,
maybe I'll take it and don't jerk off and the eight later.
Wow.
Bill.
Why,
why?
You know,
it was so family friendly right up until that moment.
No,
I'm just saying I don't have a,
I don't have a lot of stuff,
you know,
but the stuff I have is quality and it means something to me.
I've noticed something about myself.
Anytime I say anything kind of sensitive,
I have to say it in a gay accent to mask the fact that I feel uncomfortable
opening up,
you know?
So anyway,
so let's get on with this.
This is the Monday morning podcast.
I do one of these every single week unless there's a little sort of glitch with
my host,
which is the first time it's ever happened.
So just bear with me and just go with this.
I do one of these every week,
I think.
I think I've earned the right to say that.
All right,
Andy.
I answer people's questions.
People send me their list of overrated,
underrated.
They asked me for advice for some God knows reason and uh,
lately people who send sending me stories about revenge.
But here's a new topic that I guess this guy was trying to say.
I introduced and I kind of dropped the ball on it,
but um,
I dunno,
this is pretty good.
He's talking about songs that annoy him,
which are basically any top 40 songs.
His songs you hear all the time and uh,
or maybe like,
I think the topic he was talking about was annoying things in sports and I
brought up how at the red sox home games they play sweet Caroline.
I believe during the seventh inning stretch.
That's how much I hate that song is,
I'm a huge red sox fan and I don't even know when they play it.
I believe that's when they do it.
I always just,
I just turned the channel.
I can't,
I can't handle it.
And you know,
I know him from there and I don't,
it shouldn't be trashed and red sox fans,
but I don't give a shit.
But if you go to Fenway park and you start singing along to that song with your
arm around your girlfriend and y'all look up in the air and you go,
bub,
you're a fucking embarrassment.
You a fucking embarrassment stopped doing that.
Isn't it bad enough that we have a mascot now for the Red Sox?
You know what I mean?
Maybe it's cause I don't have any fucking kids,
but you know,
can we be men,
you know?
Is that like against the rules?
Now do you know a long time ago,
I might have talked about this before,
but a long time ago,
back in the day,
I want to say it was in the 70s this is why the Internet's great because you can
look this up.
I swear to God,
they tried to have a mascot.
Okay.
It was called the Fenway freak.
I swear to God.
This is true.
And the thing lasted about three days,
three days in one trip out into the bleachers.
And I dunno who that poor bastard was that was inside that fucking suit.
But,
uh,
he got pelted mercilessly with any,
now that's back in the day when,
when it was bad day,
you actually got a bat,
you've got a full size fucking bat.
They wiped out a whole acre of rainforest for every fucking row of people.
And this guy got the shit kicked out.
He ain't got no,
he got beat up.
But he,
you know,
it was definitely expressed that we don't need a fucking mascot.
You know,
and this is back in the day too,
when a foul ball came into the stands,
you didn't give it to a kid.
You stepped on a kid to give yourself another foot of height so you could steal
it from some other fucking guy.
That's how it worked,
you know?
But now,
you know,
we got to give it to a kid.
Fuck the kid.
Yeah,
give it to a kid.
He did.
He pay for his ticket.
Is He paid for parking?
Hasn't he gotten enough?
You don't even realize how lucky you are.
I was a kid.
You ever think about that shit when you were like,
tell me about when you were like six years old.
You just had no money.
You went outside to play with no ID,
no money,
no keys to the house,
just empty pockets and you just fucking went outside and somehow it,
you know,
it all worked out.
Try doing that as an adult.
Walk out of Your House without your keys,
identity or any sort of fucking money.
And I challenge you to walk around the block away from where you live without
collapsing in a full panic attack.
These fucking kids,
they don't know how good they got it and they're going to get a foul ball on top
of it.
Fuck you.
God Damn it.
I hate that.
I Dunno.
I Dunno if I hate kids or I hate their parents.
I don't know what it is.
I like kids.
You know what I like?
I like a,
I saw a kid the other day,
this toddler,
you know what's funny about toddlers,
you know when they're like two years old is you know,
parents always have him like running around shirtless.
They always have like that little beer belly.
It's the funniest fucking,
I cannot not laugh when I see that shift because what I love is this.
So like not even self conscious,
anybody.
I was a gut,
we sucks it in.
But when you're two years old,
you know,
give a fuck,
just walk,
they look like little truck drivers.
I just think this shit's hilarious.
So anyways,
what am I talking about?
So a,
so this dude was basically talking about,
uh,
just talk about,
you know,
the new topic.
Maybe it's things that annoy you in sports.
And for me,
I mean I picked on my own team,
um,
and I also,
I think I mentioned,
I can't tell if this guy was bringing it up or if I had mentioned it before,
but I'll give him credit and agree with him is when they have that old cop come
in and he sings,
God bless America in Yankee Stadium.
Like I've never wanted to throw a toaster through a flat screen more.
When he gets up there and he does that whole long beginning,
there's all blah blah,
then just fucking goes on for like 19 minutes.
It's uh,
it's just the worst.
Yeah,
I dunno.
I hate that whole thing.
I will say hate how the Yankees play New York,
New York,
whether they win or lose,
it just seems bizarre to me.
And it was really funny the night when the red sox finally beat them and hung
the biggest show.
Can Professional sports history around their fucking necks.
And the second is over,
the red sox had jumping all over the field and that playing that fucking song
that,
that at a stat spread ooze.
Is everybody teary eyed?
I don't,
maybe it's a tradition.
I have no idea.
But I'm speaking of which ESPN recently did a top 25 chokes of all time and the
Yankees of 2004 we're nowhere on the list.
They had like Greg Norman.
I was really surprised by that.
But I guess it's because,
you know,
when you dominate an entire century,
eventually you're going to have a bad year.
So I kind of understood it.
And of course the red sox made the list.
I think we were a number seven through 18.
I think we were the top,
we have the top 11 fucking jokes of all time.
Uh,
but anyway,
speaking of that,
did anybody watch the masters?
I actually,
uh,
played nine holes of golf,
a par three.
And I've never given a shit about golf.
I never kept score.
I used to sneak into a private golf course when I was a kid with my buddy during
the wintertime,
you know,
when it was no snow on the ground and we would play golf,
but it was more like a,
it was more like Polo,
you know,
it wasn't a stroke thing.
It was more like a who could get the ball in the hole first.
So there was a lot of,
uh,
you know,
standing in front of somebody off to the side as they were shooting and you were
shooting two and he fucking slices it and the hitching your back,
uh,
you know,
that kind of shit.
And then you play like five holes and then you don't give a fuck.
And then you just start trying to drive golf balls at the building next to the
golf course.
We played golf like that.
So anyways,
long story short,
uh,
I actually had a good time when this par three course and I actually part one of
the holes and I started to be like,
man,
I think I may want to play this fucking game.
So I got fucking,
I'll watch the master's,
I'll see what's going on.
You know,
I bet a little money with my good friend Keith Robinson who a,
he's part of my,
my,
uh,
I think he made the first row of my top 9,000 friends.
And uh,
he's,
he's a man of African descent,
so,
you know,
I'm sick of them talking about tiger woods and how fucking great he is and all
his shit.
So I call up Keith and I tell him that,
you know what,
I'm willing to bet against tiger.
I'm wanting to put my money on a fucking white man to a beat d a tiger woods,
you know,
so he goes,
I'll take it about 20 bucks a text,
Phil Mickelson and I beat that motherfucker by one stroke.
So anyway,
so I get totally into this master's and I'm watching the end of it thinking it's
going to be this very cool thing.
It was most unsatisfying winning of a championship I've ever experienced as a
fan because the Guy Kenny Perry,
48 years old,
he had the fucking thing one.
Okay,
he birdies 16 he's up by two strokes with two holes to go.
He bogeys his 17th bogeys the 18th and then loses the two round playoff.
It was,
it was one of the saddest things I've ever seen and it's like what I really
realize is golf is the worst sport to choke him because you choke in anything
else.
Let's take the red sox.
The ball goes,
who bucked his leg?
How long did that take?
Like what?
Like fucking two and a half seconds.
Dude.
This guy,
Kenny Perry,
choked for like 90 minutes,
an hour and a half on national television,
slicing it,
hooking it,
going into the trap in front of his whole fucking family and the show in his
family that Diana's slow death.
His fucking wife couldn't even look at him at the end of it.
It was just,
it was who's fucking horrible.
I actually woke up the next day thinking about going,
God,
if he just chose a different club.
I don't know if you're a Kenny Perry fan or you know,
I,
I feel real bad for that guy.
It was one of the worst fucking things I've ever seen in my life,
so I don't think I'm ever going to watch golf again.
I'm done with it.
Although I might start playing it and thus complete the circle of being a a,
a white man,
you know?
Isn't that what I'm supposed to do?
Cross my legs with penny loafers and start pontificating like I know how shit
works as I wait to tee off,
isn't the one I'm supposed to be doing.
You know,
certainly by the time I'm 50 dress like I'm in the,
in a three stooges sketch.
I love how they always do address like in there in the 1920s and they were one
of those black panther berets,
but it has a pump palm on it.
All right?
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking about.
Let's get back to this kid's list.
This kid made a list of his top eight,
which I love.
Who if people do a top five,
top three,
top 10,
who does a top eight?
I'll tell you who this motherfucker,
he's doing his top eight songs that just,
he never needs to hear again.
He basically said if I were all powerful,
I would begin by outlawing these things,
which I think is a great new topic to another new topic.
Okay?
Not only do you got the things that annoy you in sports,
how about what if you were a dictator and you could make laws?
What would you outlaw?
And this,
he's,
this kid is just going with music.
All right?
Number eight.
He said,
sweet Caroline,
as I just went off on,
um,
number seven hotel,
California.
He goes,
I don't give a shit where you living it up?
You overrated Pansy.
He's got a lot of anger towards all these artists,
hotel California.
Can we,
can we admit that that song never needs to be played again?
Piano man,
horrific song,
horrific song.
He knew.
What's the worst part of this song is I think it's in three four isn't it saying
as is Rianna man.
One,
two,
three,
one,
two,
three,
one,
two,
three,
one,
two,
three,
one and everybody starts fucking rocking back and forth like the right October
fest as that's the fuck.
You know,
it's a great moment in a bar and I swear to God,
it's right out of a Benny Hill sketch.
You ever see somebody with a beer in their hand and they checked to see what
time it is and their watches on the same hand is,
it's never not funny.
I saw a guy we would drink and after an la kings game
and you don't like when you go to make a point like,
you know what the fuck and he kind of throw your hands out to the side.
He did that with a full beer in his hand and literally just through like,
it looked like a lake of beer onto this,
this table where there was like,
you know,
three women sitting at,
which made it even funnier.
You know what I mean?
Cause they're all just like,
well,
I never,
um,
anyways,
let's,
let's continue weight number number five,
living on a prayer.
Absolutely.
I would say the entire Bon Jovi catalog other than,
uh,
that wanted song,
that's a guilty pleasure.
It's on my fucking iPod.
I'm not apologizing for it.
And I actually learned how to play the beginning on the guitar and,
uh,
and it made me happy.
I'm such a fucking loser.
All right,
number four,
sweet home Alabama.
And that's still one that's on the fence.
It's such a good fucking song.
But yeah,
they've really played the hell out of it.
And I love how,
uh,
I think somebody wrapped over that.
I think I talked about this before.
Some rapper rap to that sample and it's spending a couple of movies that I
noticed black people kind of start bobbing their heads when that song comes on.
And uh,
if you're black,
you should really look up the lyrics to that song and I don't think he'd be
bobbing your head.
You probably be shaking it.
Um,
all right,
number three.
Mustang Sally.
Yeah,
that song's for like cougars chicks to start fucking shaking.
They're dusty muffs too.
You know,
it's a grind up on some fucking 20 year old kid who really wants to bang you
because he's got some sort of weird issue with older women because his mother
didn't stick around that home.
Cougar seen is just the creepiest,
it's every bit is creepy as the 50 year old guy date and that the fucking 18
year old chick,
that whole daddy thing going on,
it's just,
it's really a,
it's creepy,
but I'm not gonna lie to you.
If I was 50 and single and I could,
ah,
how low would you go?
Do you ever think about that?
Like right now I'm 40 can be 41 in June.
Uh,
25,
25 is my cutoff.
Uh,
maybe 24.
She listened to jazz.
She seemed mature.
Um,
yeah.
All I know is you can't be in college.
I remember one time when I was 35,
I hooked up with a 21 year olds and in the process of air quotes here seducing
her,
I actually said,
so what's your major?
And I almost,
I almost pulled the plug right there.
But fortunately my dick was running things at that point and I was able to see
the mission through.
All right.
Number two,
uh,
brown eyed girl.
I don't mind that song.
Fam Morrison.
You know,
maybe it's,
is that Van Morrison,
you know Brown,
I girl,
do you remember when?
Oh yeah.
You know,
that's one of those songs that everyone sings in a bar and it just makes you
hate humanity.
I'll give you that one.
And his number one song is a American pie.
Oh yeah,
that's a,
that's a song that's like really dramatic for no reason.
Even though I know that they're singing about,
uh,
the big bopper and Ritchie valance and a buddy Holly all dying.
This wasn't the guy to do the song.
Now,
just it just really slow and you know,
Madonna did a cover of that song.
Talk about,
you know,
okay,
two horrific worlds colliding.
I'll tell you this,
if I,
if I could,
if I could pick my top,
I'll just give you my top three.
Um,
number three is the entire beyond say catalog.
And that includes all of her work with destiny child,
Destiny's child.
I think she's a beautiful woman.
She's a great dancer,
but she cannot sing.
I think she's singing too high and then,
and then it's just,
Ugh,
those fucking,
I haven't heard hooks like that since the last time j lo had a fucking album
out.
I mean,
that song she had out and they just kept playing that saxophone over and over
again.
Did it,
did,
it did.
I did.
It did.
And you just wanted to fucking smash a glass into the person next to you.
Like they like punish you with the music.
That's what,
like Beyonce songs,
they're like,
I don't get it.
Like Beyonce.
Sing as high as you can and then sing the same thing over and over and over and
over and over again.
Maybe like in a minute,
20 minutes later,
all her beauty goes down the fucking drain.
The second she starts singing Jesus,
I'm in a mood.
So all her entire catalog.
MMM.
Anything by kiss.
And I'm going to pause here to let everybody be like,
oh,
she's crying.
Tears.
Come on man.
Just go Detroit rock city.
It all sucks.
It's horrific.
You could take fucking Bob Seger with them.
There's a lot of bad white music coming out of Detroit.
I'm telling you.
Um,
and the number one would be thin Lizzy.
The boys are back in town and uh,
they should be like a contest.
Like to just see how long you can listen to that song.
It's like they just singing about these fucking,
this group of Douche bags that just like thinks they're bad asses.
I guess.
You know,
I haven't,
I talked about this before.
I can't even fucking remember.
I've done some of these podcasts.
They got it.
The boys are back in town and they get that holds the ball.
If the boys want to fight,
you better let them really harassed.
What
you know,
man,
that chick slap Giani in the face.
Man,
we fell about the place.
You know,
like everyone's just sitting around this town.
Wait for these fucking Douche bags to show back up.
You know,
come back into town.
all fuck the boys are back in town.
Hide the women.
These fucking nerds are back in town and if they want to fight you better let
them
whoever wrote that song should seriously consider killing themselves,
you know?
Yeah,
it's right up there with Woodrow Wilson Pushing through the Federal Reserve Act.
That's number one.
And number two is whoever wrote the boys are back in town.
That's how I see that shit.
All right,
so let's move on here.
Let's get on with the podcast.
Uh,
what do we got here and what do we got here?
All right,
this here is not really a revenge story.
This is actually a,
dare I say,
kind of clever.
What this guy did to fuck somebody over he a,
this is what he did.
He took,
I don't know,
a lot of this computer stuff,
so I'm going to try to read this slowly and God knows,
we all know I suck at reading out loud at this point.
Okay.
All right.
He says,
uh,
I took us,
basically what I did was I took a screen capture of my friends desktop when he
left his computer on attended,
which basically means he took a picture of it,
of the guys desktop.
I guess he didn't have anything on the screen.
He just took a picture of it.
He goes,
I then hid all his desktop icons and set the background as this screen capture I
just took.
So basically it looks like all his,
all the folders and icons are still there,
but they're not.
So when the dude comes back,
you'll be clicking till his fucking mouth starts smoking and nothing will
happen.
Man.
Come on man.
You got to give this guy an a for effort.
That's just pretty,
uh,
I think that's kind of ingenious.
So anyways,
I guess this is how it plays out.
He goes,
I waited for the guy to return to see his reaction.
I stood off in the distance,
like a fucking stalker.
He goes,
at first I could see the confused look on his face,
but it very quickly turned to frustration and then anger.
He began mumbling shit like this fucking piece of shit.
And it escalated to him pretty much yelling and saying,
I'm going to smash this motherfucker.
He goes,
I couldn't believe it.
He was pounding the keyboard and slamming the mouse.
I was laughing so hard that snap was coming out of my nose.
So the dude concluded that he had a virus.
So he took the computer to the it department.
They figured it out in five minutes and told them he's an asshole.
What do you think?
Did I do good or am I the Douche bag or the week?
Nah,
dude,
you did great.
That's fucking hilarious.
Okay.
That's a great idea.
I wish I knew something about computers.
I would try that on somebody.
I tried that on my girlfriend.
That's the kind of guy I go.
Um,
no,
you're not a Douche to that Sa.
I don't know if he came up with that,
but that's pretty,
uh,
that's pretty ingenious.
So I give you a thumbs up on that one.
And everybody at work,
go ahead.
Go try that on your boss.
No,
I don't do it to your boss because someone will end up renting the house and
eventually,
even if they didn't rat you out,
they could figure out that you were the one who did it because you would be
doing that.
You know that laugh and you didn't in school when you were a kid,
you weren't allowed to laugh and you would hold your nose.
So He'd start making those duck noises.
That usually gives away that you're the one who fucking did it.
All right,
let's get on with revenge stories.
Um,
before I get on with the revenge stories,
uh,
some woman was letting me know why females are better at revenge than guys.
And she wrote a pretty interesting thing here.
Uh,
she says,
cause I guess I was asking all my podcast a couple of weeks ago,
how come his revenge only a guy thing.
How come I'm not hearing from women?
And believe me,
if you hear the stories this week,
uh,
I really opened the flood gates because the women,
the ladies,
they came in strong this week.
So before I read all the women revenge stories here,
uh,
this woman,
his,
there's a little preamble setup she gives me,
she goes,
Bill,
you've only read one revenge story from a female.
And I'll tell you why guys are idiotic and deal with anger.
So stupidly
is stupidly a word.
Yeah,
isn't it?
Guys are idiotic and they deal with their anger in a stupid way.
Okay?
I Dunno,
I'm too fucking stupid to know.
But that would be hilarious if stupidly is not a word,
you know,
because you just made yourself look like an ass.
And if you didn't,
I apologize.
Let me continue a fucking up.
Someone's car is pathetic.
This kind of revenge is temporary.
Doing something like that would just make someone think of you as a cock sock
and jackass and then I'll move on with their lives.
Women can and will remember my new details and situations that guys will forget
when we want to know,
when we know how someone works,
we know how to use it against him.
Physical is temporary.
Psychological is permanent.
Women can do the most damage with the least effort.
We don't aim to screw someone over or to do something to piss someone off.
We aim for resentment.
Resentment is much more powerful because it places you in a higher status and
when someone resents you,
it's most likely that you have something that they don't and that you are just
better than them in some way.
So my point is that lashing out at someone is stupid.
It only makes you feel better and doesn't really have or accomplished much
longtime effect on the other.
All right,
now I want to tell you something,
you guys,
that paragraph right there is why I've never gotten married because I realize
that women have that.
You know they got that in them.
You know that expression?
Hell hath no fury like a woman scorned.
That's the deal.
It's this weird thing that when they're dating you and they want to know
everything about you,
it's this odd thing where half of it is so they can love the whole you and the
other half is like,
it's collateral in case the thing goes bad.
They have all this fucked up information that they can use against you.
So,
uh,
I don't know,
that was pretty chilling to read that.
And uh,
I don't agree with their definition of resentments saying that it,
it,
uh,
it means that you have something that they don't or that you are just better
than them in some way.
Uh,
I don't think,
I think they resent you because you fucked him over,
you know,
not because you drive a better car.
Right.
I Dunno.
Why don't I shut the fuck up and read the first revenge story.
All right.
His,
no,
this is all from the,
this is all from women this week and I gotta tell you something.
They really,
really take it to the next level and uh,
yeah.
All right,
let's just get on with this.
All right.
And on this one,
I'm not going to tell the street.
There's a couple of names and street names and here I don't wanna get anybody in
trouble.
So here we go.
Bill.
This story is actually not mine,
but,
um,
I was a participant.
Um,
you know what?
I'm going to say the names because I'm not going to try to fucking remember fake
names.
I'm just not going to say the name of the street.
All right.
Right after I graduated from college,
I moved to,
okay.
I can't say that my roommates were still college students is sometimes their
friends,
which were also my friends.
We all went to the same college,
stayed.
Uh,
they'd stay over.
One of our friends,
uh,
Jess,
who still lived in the dorm,
was having problems with a roommate.
Gale,
her roommate knew she had an eating disorder and was spreading rumors about her
writing things on our mirror.
Like,
you're fat.
We let just stay at our apartment.
And we started plot,
started to plot revenge.
One of the things we did was crank called gale.
So in case she got lost in that,
I guess Jess is the anorexic one and Gail is the cont.
All right.
Okay.
Let's continue on.
One of the things we did was crank call Gail.
We,
we use the voice from my roommates Mac computer and typed out some evil shit.
This definitely made just feel better and I guess inspired her to pull the
ultimate revenge.
Jess was a teen before she went to college.
This is the anorexic girl.
While in college she worked at a high scale I high scale salon on something,
something street.
Shortly after we crank called Gail just ran into gales boyfriend after work.
According to Jess,
she brought Gail's boyfriend back to her,
their dorm room,
fuck him in Gail's bed and then called Gail right after to tell her all the
details.
Just ended up staying in our apartment the rest of the semester and bought us a
$200 bottle of champagne to celebrate the act of revenge.
At the time,
I thought Gail got what she deserved,
but in hindsight it made me realize that women are evil.
Manipulative bitches.
Yes.
Many women hate being called fat,
but it ceases to amaze me,
but it never ceases to amaze me that women,
what women will do to others,
other women to get back at him.
Wow.
You know what I mean?
He'd take it to that level.
Uh,
I dunno who deserves what in that story,
but I think the real winner is a Gail's boyfriend.
You know,
you have a one that if you're a guy,
you ever wonder if any girl was fucking you outta revenge just to get somebody
back.
You know?
I don't think that's ever happened to me.
I don't live that exciting a life,
but I can't imagine.
Okay.
What is,
what do you say is the guys,
she sitting there banging you?
Yeah.
That'll show her slip over and I'll bust it on your face.
You really taught her a lesson.
Hey,
anytime you want to teach,
teach her a lesson.
Again,
this is,
let me know.
I really,
I'm really down with you.
I understand your point here and I think a,
you're very justified.
You know,
you don't really make really drive the point home is you let me,
if you let me bang you again,
you know,
and if you really want to get the ultimate,
ultimate revenge,
you'd let me put it in your ass.
You know,
I'm just throwing these ideas out there.
I mean,
this is,
this is your world.
You know,
I'm just,
I'm just here to help.
Okay?
So that's revenge story number one.
Um,
and I can see,
you know,
in order it is,
it's not that she fucked the girl's boyfriend that she called him up,
called her up and told her about it.
You know,
that's one of the advantages of women is for the most part,
they don't have to worry about the other woman coming over and just beating the
shit out of her.
Because as a guy,
if you ever tried to get back and another guy and you banged his girlfriend,
you'd never call the dude,
because I don't even care if you could beat the guy in a fight on a normal
basis.
You know what I'm saying?
The level of anger that he would have.
He,
I think he'd still win.
Right?
Does that make any sense?
All right.
Let me plow ahead that.
Jesus already up to 31 minutes.
Let me get through these here.
All right.
Hey Bill.
Here's my story of revenge.
Everybody knows that women hate each other,
hate other women.
And I have a great story about women's revenge.
I was roommates with two other women in college.
One was very average looking and one was very beautiful.
The type of beautiful that makes all the other girls around her hater.
Um,
she got whatever she wanted throughout her life because of,
because of it.
Guys,
money,
grades,
you name it.
And she was a bitch.
She used everyone around her and was never said no to.
Um,
so I was casually dating a guy and brought him back to my house.
And both my roommates were there.
We hung out with them for awhile and everything was cool.
I didn't notice anything unusual.
A few weeks later,
I hear from a mutual friend that my roommate,
I guess the hot one was out with my guy after.
Seriously interrogating my guy.
He finally spills his guts and tells me the truth.
I would have loved to have seen that guys have the worst liars ever know what
was what was doing
fucking 12 seconds later.
All right.
You got me.
I was fucking her.
Anyways,
he goes,
uh,
she had,
the hot girl had bumped into the,
her boyfriend on campus one day,
and I guess they headed off and started seeing each other by my back.
Um,
naturally I dump his ass,
but I'm so much more pissed at her.
I kinda read that weird.
So it's her boyfriend.
Um,
okay.
So anyways,
uh,
I come up with a brilliant plan to get my revenge on her and enlisted my other
roommates for help.
She agrees because all average girls secretly hate pretty girls.
This is really eye opening about the,
uh,
the psycho inner worlds of women.
This is like an HBO undercover.
So anyways,
here's that revenge.
Uh,
we had an,
an advantage because the hot girl,
she drank a lot and we get ripped almost every other night and I mean really,
really ripped.
We'd wait until she gets,
uh,
so one night we waited until she got loaded one night and it was the most wasted
I've ever seen her.
It was like all the stars were aligned for our plan.
She had beautiful long corn.
Silkair uh oh,
here we go.
Here we go.
She had beautiful long corn.
Silkair care was straight off the ass of a golden retriever.
I bought two boxes of black hair dye and after she passes out,
we started.
I really wanted to make a statement,
so I partner hair down the middle and only die half of her head,
Jesus Christ.
After I start,
I turned into this crazy die hungry freak.
I couldn't stop myself.
I started dying any part of her body that could,
that I could find.
I did our eyebrows,
the peach fuzz on her chin and lip,
her fingers and our arms.
I'm embarrassed to say that we even died a lightning bolt in her pubic hair.
The funny part was that she kept waking up telling us to leave her alone,
but we kept going,
Jesus,
this,
this sounds like a fucking date rape story.
It's just that as women.
So I guess is,
it's still funny.
Anybody else getting creeped out here?
Um,
let's continue here.
Of course,
we were too lazy to wash it out,
so if we just go to sleep and leave the black hair dye on our roommate for about
seven hours,
I wake up the next day to her and a towel towel.
Her hair was soaking wet and she was beating the shit out of me with a shampoo
bottle.
It was fucking hysterical.
The dye had stained or skin along with their hair,
so she had dark brown patches all over her face and body.
She looked like the bastard child of Cruella Deville and Richard Grieco.
I don't know who that is.
I was so proud of my work.
You would think that I got my revenge,
but this is a story about her revenge on me.
This is a fucking long one here.
Plot twist.
She actually called the cops and they fucking came and arrested my roommate and
me.
The evidence was stacked against us because our hands and arms were also stained
with black hair.
Dye her bed where the crime was committed was covered in black dye.
It looked like an octopus had been raped in there.
She tried to charge us with sexual assault,
a pubic hair,
lightening bolt.
Yeah.
You know,
you pull somebody's pants down,
start dying their genitals,
or at least the area.
Yeah,
you're gonna get in trouble.
So anyways,
after spending all day in the police station,
we were finally let out and the charges were dropped.
But when we got back to the house,
we were greeted by campus security and our parents were there too.
Trying to explain to your dad why you died.
Some other girls,
pubic hair,
not fun.
The fucking bitch.
God is kicked out of the house and we put on strict probation.
It was a big deal.
We almost literally almost got kicked out of school.
The worst part was when we were moving out of the house.
About a week later,
she shows up with my ex boyfriend and she looks amazing.
She had died the rest of her hair black and cut it in this cute short Bob Style
and waxed off all the body hair.
She was as beautiful as ever.
And then she writes in capital letters,
cunt.
I felt like such an ass,
like there was no way to get back at this bitch.
I guess my life isn't over.
So someday I will get her back.
I'll make sure to fill you in.
Okay.
Well I know you haven't asked my advice,
but uh,
I think you should just let that one go there.
A sweetheart.
I think,
uh,
you know,
sometimes you just gotta say fuck it.
Uh,
isn't that unbelievable?
I mean,
things like reverse that and if,
if you,
okay,
if you did that as a guy,
if you did that same thing as a guy,
you would literally be in a prison shower right now with half a mop handle
trying to fight off five rapist.
But if you know you have a vagina,
all you get,
you just get kicked out of your house.
It's fucking incredible.
I still a bit about that shit.
How having a vagina just keeps you out of jail.
You know,
like,
like give us see,
like when a mob boss gets arrested,
you know,
they never take the wife,
like she doesn't know what the fuck he's doing.
Oh,
I just thought he was a baker.
I thought he was really,
really good at making cookies.
And that's why I had 20 furs and lived in a lived in a mansion.
You know what the fuck he was doing,
you know,
and you spend all that blood money and you,
and you don't end up fucking going to jail.
It's a,
there's something about it.
Like they just don't,
uh,
like remember that movie monster's ball,
not monsters,
ball.monster where they literally turned a serial killer into this sympathetic
fucking person.
I just didn't,
you know.
Yeah.
He had a rough childhood.
You know,
you got molested.
What?
You know,
who didn't go write some fucking jokes.
You don't get a gun and start shooting fucking people.
And if you do,
you go to jail.
That'll happen.
But that movie was the worst fucking movie ever with those cartoon character
male characters that they had and that,
did you see?
You remember that part where she goes into apply for the law office job or
something?
She comes in there looking like this strung out hooker,
and somehow she's not ushered right out of the fucking office.
She actually gets in to the lawyers office and he's just like,
let me tell you something.
You fucking skank.
He's like,
there's over the top.
I really hated that fucking movie.
And I hate when beautiful actresses don't wear makeup.
And then the,
everybody falls all over themselves and talks about how brave it is.
It was so brave.
He was so brave.
All right,
let's continue on here.
let me read the last one here,
Bill.
Uh,
for the past two weeks I've made my girlfriend listened to your podcast.
Incidentally,
she loves it.
This past week she told me about how she got revenge on her ex boyfriend off.
This one is brutal and it's,
it's very,
uh,
doesn't,
there's no fat on this one.
This one's great because she doesn't get caught.
There's nothing,
you know,
I don't know ruin here,
but this,
listen to this.
After that messy breakup,
she logged onto their shared jet blue,
a cow,
you know,
they're going out.
You know,
I gave her gently that taking trips.
So they got this JetBlue account and I evidently they boast had the password,
so she logs onto it and she saw that the Douche bag and his new girlfriend had
booked a vacation.
Well,
the morning of their scheduled trip on the morning of the scheduled trip,
she logged on and canceled the flight.
Can you imagine what a pain in the ass that must've been for them anyways,
she never saw any activity on the account again.
I thought that this was pretty funny.
A lot more subtler than king someone's car,
like a little bitch and whatever and whatever.
That other moron,
wait,
I'm reading this one and whatever that other more on girl did on the other
week's podcast.
Wow,
man,
that is,
that is dirty pool right there.
If the guy cheated on you,
yeah,
I can see that.
But if you just had a messy breakup,
that's uh,
that's been addictive.
That's really fucked up.
A lot of these things are really a really fucked up.
You know that die in that girl's pubic hair.
That's,
that's really,
uh,
you need a hobby at that point.
All right?
Why don't I stop judging people?
I asked for your fucking revenge stories and now I'm judging you.
All right?
Whatever gets overrated,
underrated,
a overrated karaoke.
Hate it.
Terrible songs sung by people who can't sing you,
which are usually fat chicks and gay guys,
and the off chance that you and your drunk friends find yourself at a karaoke
bar singing eighties hair metal songs.
There's always those douchebags and interrupt the fun with a serious gay country
song.
You know,
I love about this guy.
He says,
Garrick Karaoke is overrated.
Like people actually love it.
Okay?
Then he says that it's stocks and then in the middle of it,
he admits doing it.
But evidently when he and his douchebag friends go up there and sing eighties
hair metal songs,
that's totally fine.
You know?
But when someone comes up to sing us,
kick a country song,
they are gay.
Dude,
I hate to tell you this,
but you're part of the fucking problem.
I'm actually,
you know what,
actually if you sing an eighties hair metal song and a karaoke thing,
I'm gonna Laugh my ass off.
And uh,
I liked that better.
Just as long as someone doesn't go well,
what are the,
what are the fucking tunes?
Those ships,
I always end up singing.
Uh,
what does that song on that guy sings about losing his virginity?
That,
oh,
what a nice
little bag and 63,
if some reason women love that fucking song and uh,
this is nothing worse than the female voice,
like 12 of them all singing in a really high voice.
It's like a car alarm going off.
All right,
I think we're done for the week.
How are we,
what are we up to?
42 minutes.
Alright.
Ask Bill is this,
is this podcast petering out here?
I think I'm doing too much reading and not telling enough stories.
All right,
let's,
let's read this one here.
Um,
okay.
Bill.
Uh,
I'm almost 26 and a bunch of my friends still love going to the clubs at night
and on weekends.
Uh,
now I'm not sure that I'm,
if I'm getting too old for it or just,
or if I just can't stand people.
But absolutely the hate going to these places.
I know as a guy who's supposed to go in there and get girls,
but I just can't take it anymore.
No matter which place it is.
It always feels like you should get a mandatory penicillin shout when you leave
because a group of sweaty skanky people crammed into a room,
grinding to crappy techno music is just disgusting.
That combined with the guys with the sonic,
the hedgehog haircut just drives me crazy,
especially when they're the ones getting all the girls.
Um,
is it me or is these places truly horrific?
And at what stage?
Uh,
at what and or what age were you officially the old fuck at the club?
Um,
all right.
All right,
dude.
Tough.
You're being too hard on yourself.
First of all,
you're only 26 years old.
You're in the prime of your life.
You should be going out talking to women.
You just doing it in a,
in a bar that's not you.
You know what I mean?
Like basically everybody's a douchebag.
Okay.
But you got to hang out with the same kind of Douche bags so you feel
comfortable.
You know what I mean?
Like me,
I'm a loner,
psycho Douche bag.
So I used to hang out in dive bars and,
uh,
who the fuck am I kidding?
Did I,
then,
I don't think I ever picked up a girl in a bar.
I always met him at gyms amount.
I'm on the subway a lot in New York.
Um,
I,
I meet him when they're not ready.
You know,
like women don't have their guard up sometimes,
like on the train,
they have their guard up to get mugged,
not to be hit on,
I guess.
I Dunno.
Maybe I just felt like,
you know,
I would never did well in those singles bars.
Like,
you know,
it's almost like as a comedian,
someone goes,
you're a comedian.
All right,
say something funny.
It's just like,
you've ruined the moment.
So I would still go out,
just find,
uh,
you know,
find,
find the right place to hang out.
He can't hang it up at 26 unless you live in the middle of Kansas and you might
as well fucking read a Bible and knock up some broad and have eight kids and
vote for a fucking retard over and over again for eight fucking years.
Okay.
That was a little mean.
All right.
A question of the week,
a bill,
I was wondering how you handle two shows a one night I was part of the lake
crowd tonight and you killed what was,
was it the same scenario in the earlier show with a joke said bombed in the
earliest show where their jokes in the,
in the earlier show that bombed that you skipped on the second shell.
Uh,
no.
You know,
if it bombed them to stop her and I'm going to keep doing it,
but I'm doing two shows in one night.
I tried to switch it up,
you know,
I just don't want the wait staff and everybody to know exactly how am I actually
going to go.
Um,
because that's a big thing on the second show and your three,
three days into your weekend gig.
If,
uh,
you see like the waitresses smiling and stuff and laughing as they're bringing
drinks over to the table,
that's like one of the best compliments you can get because,
uh,
nobody sees more comedy or listens to more comedy than comedy club waitresses
because as a comedian,
if I see a comic and I don't let go what he's doing,
I can walk out of the room.
But as a,
as a waitress,
you have to,
you got to keep going back in,
you know,
and,
uh,
so if you can get the,
you know,
so they get jaded really as far as like,
what's funny and I'm so,
um,
I didn't know if I answered your question,
but,
no,
I don't really,
I know what I'm going to start with and I know what I'm going to finish with.
I don't really know what's going to be in the middle.
Okay.
But I definitely switch up the jokes just so I don't feel like,
like that groundhog day thing where everything's the same.
So,
uh,
all right.
There's that.
All Right,
Bill,
I've been listening to your podcasts and I watched you perform because it's nice
to hear that someone used the word cunt every five minutes.
You don't seem to curse as much when you're performing,
but you're getting to be like,
uh,
some of the other dirty comics out there on your podcast.
I think it's quite hilarious.
How use the word to describe anyone that's pissing you off through unnecessary
though one necessary most of the time.
Um,
in addition.
Okay.
Oh,
wait a minute.
I already read this already.
Read this tonight.
This is,
this lady asked me about Saint Patrick's Day.
That was from Cleveland.
I already read that.
All right,
so I guess that is the end of the podcast for this week.
Um,
please give me the feedback,
what you think about the new,
uh,
the new stereo sound.
I know I need to make some adjustments.
I know I might've been too close to it a couple of times and I know that there's
like an echo in the room now and uh,
I'll put some egg empty egg shelf traits on the fucking side of my walls.
But whatever.
So,
uh,
so that's the deal.
Um,
just to let you know
my upcoming gigs,
I'm going to be at Iowa state this weekend,
April 18th,
and that is a private show.
That show is only for the students of Iowa state.
You need a student Id to get into the show
or
if you kind of look young and you have a baseball cap,
maybe you can sneak your way in,
but you didn't hear that from me.
Um,
the following weekend I'm going to be at the funny bone in Columbus and the
weekend after that it'll be a Carolina to New York City.
Okay.
Um,
young Joe to Roselle.
We'll be opening for me on both of those shows.
And then if you'll notice on my,
uh,
my website,
I had to blow out a number of dates.
Tempe,
Ireland,
Cleveland and Atlanta are all being rescheduled and I can't really tell you why
as of yet.
I'm going to leave you hanging.
How do you like that?
Huh?
Like one of those old fucking Batman and Robin when they're stuck in the machine
and they're going to fucking die and he got to wait till next week.
Yeah,
I can't really tell you.
I can't actually,
I can't tell you for a minute.
I kind of a,
something may or may not be going on and I needed to free up my schedule and at
some point actually in June I'll be able to let you know.
So
that's the deal.
That's the Monday morning podcast.
And if you like this,
the device I'm using is the Olympus ls 10.
This fucking thing is a,
it's pretty incredible and I'm going to have a my own mic next weekend.
Me and Joe Derosa going to be continuing our uninformed show as a podcast on the
uh,
my space.com/uninformed radio.
And we're going to be using this device with a couple of microphones and I think
we're going to be doing an episode next week and we're going to put it up there
and it's going to sound lovely and that's it.
And I feel like I'm born.
Yeah,
so that's it.
Everybody.
Thanks for listening and please keep the questions coming and,
uh,
feel free to keep sending me,
you know,
things from past topics and if you want to do them for the,
uh,
the new ones,
songs,
your top fucking,
your top eight songs that annoy you and shit.
And in a sports that,
fuck shit.
All right.
That's it.
Everybody have a good before.
[inaudible].